[Music]  people are gearing up for fireworks you  got barbecues here's the problem though  the economy's in kind of rough shape  most people on a tight budget so here  with some money saving fourth of July  tips  once again our prop master bill tall  bill pick a lint roller roll it in corn  boom corn on the cob  [Applause]  here's bill with another tip take a rice  cake draw black lines on it boom  hamburger  here's another one take your wife  introduce her to your other wife boom  fireworks  what that works actually yeah another  one take your underwear rip out the  bottoms boom Independence Day  [Applause]  last one take a sparklab boom a sparkler  they're pretty cheap  [Applause]  which science  [Applause]